let's hear from the people in the
audience these are the most important
people we missed live calls last week
because of my absence a very timely
absence I would say we do live calls via
Discord you can join the Discord at
davidpackman.com
slash Discord and we are going to start
today with George from Virginia George
from Virginia welcome to the program
what's on your mind today sir
hey David can you hear me yes I can
oh excellent excellent um so I wanted to
bring up something with RFK uh that I
think a lot of people are
kind of glossing over to focus on the
vaccine stuff okay you're talking about
Bobby Kennedy Jr Democratic presidential
candidate
yes that is correct good um
so he said I don't know if he saw he was
uh had two interviews on uh breaking
points
oh okay
well I would I would recommend you go
check him out because he reveals a lot
of information about what he wants to do
in certain areas okay
and in the first one he said something
that was really troubling
he's he said that when it comes to
climate change he believes that the
solution is having a a truly free energy
market right and
when I hear that I get very nervous
because I think of Texas right and and
Texas has I don't know if uh you know
your viewers know this but Texas has a
deregulated energy Market where
um it's supposed to drive down costs and
uh lower pollution but I look this up
Texas is actually one of the top 10 most
uh polluted states in the country and
not only that they've had these issues
where because their electrical system is
not connected to the greater grid when
they had the winter storms when they had
the summer heat waves and power outages
they were they were basically screwed
for lack of a better term because they
didn't have neighboring resources they
could pull from it's been a disaster in
Texas no listen I'm aware of what you're
saying with Bobby Kennedy Jr and uh I
know that he favors a very sort of like
pro-corporate in a sense
um situation when it comes to energy and
uh I I just don't believe that there's
evidence that that actually will work
um there are all sorts of different
reasons reasons that we could look at
including the fact that really to get us
out of the status quo in a way where we
will move in the direction of truly
renewable energy there is this interim
period during which we actually almost
certainly I believe certainly will need
government involvement through both
regulation and subsidies we're going to
need regulation and subsidies in order
to start making some really important
transitions I believe that if it's left
to the free market sure they might
happen decades later than they otherwise
would and in a way that will be
dramatically damaging to the planet so I
just told and it sounds like you agree
with me on this George I disagree with
Bobby Kennedy Jr that that's the way to
fix climate change
yeah yeah and I I think a lot of people
uh
misunderstand the fact that he as a
lawyer
can fight for for justice when it comes
to uh environmental things but his
solution as a policy maker can be bad at
the same time absolutely yeah so very
eloquently said George
oh thank you uh so yeah that was all I
had and I appreciate it David all right
George from Virginia making some
excellent points